whatever it is and whenever they decide
that oh yeah I'm pregnant open your
mouth
open your mouth
before open your mouth
oh I've got a period you got a period up
there too
you know what I mean the same way
they're moaning about because true yeah
right and like they will give their best
to all the men out there and then when
they come home when they get home later
on in like late in life it's like oh I
don't do that no you were doing it when
you're done we want the free Plaza with
the twists so women know that before it
was so lucky they dropping on their
knees as far as them because if you
couldn't do that when you're young do
when you're old your knees still work
baby hit me go for me well it's almost
like girls don't want to earn a guy
anymore it's fooling the men out there
but oh no I've got a headache you know
what I'll get rid of the headache for
you I will get rid of it
yeah that was cool Strokes you know what
I mean as far as I'm concerned turn
around and take it
I'll wake up watch the TV read a book
just over how you're on your phone yeah
they got too many excuses out there I
remember falling for it hey bigger
auntie in the building you know
and then they won me wait a minute going
out there
that needs to get clipped up there we go
they need to go out there and do it
because as far as I'm concerned some of
them women got big mouths for a reason
feel it
and they're gonna sit down there oh no I
don't do that and then you can hear from
Jack and Harry down the road oh yeah oh
yeah she gives good head you know she
could go ahead give it to your man give
it to your man that's what when the men
are talking about you've given your
goodies to somebody else because you go
there you free up for everybody else and
then you want to come back and go like
oh no I don't do that yeah you do yeah
you do if I don't want to hear the I got
a headache I got a period I got this I
got that what are the main gonna suffer
but how long you have a period for 30
years the men want to part about that
for 30 years no no they don't they don't
exactly and then we've got a problem
they're always on their period because
she's on their period before
what should she do what should he do if
she said she got a stomachache I was
helping rubber stock up
okay okay
what about a migraine there's no issues
I listen right you know that I have sex
and get rid of any headache
any headache the right sex and get rid
of it how we're not talking about all
these women that want to make love they
want the rose petals they want the
bubble bath they want the mass out come
on please the woman's got time for that
no matter what I mean before he goes to
work if a man's like you got me I've got
10 minutes no you got 10 minutes I got
two calls I've got 10 minutes for you
that's what I'm gonna let you go to work
frustrating I'm gonna give you five
words it's all right I'm gonna empty you
before you leave the house you know I
mean men need to be empty before the
house pull their belly empty their
sacks
no like I am actually such a kind of way
I agree with them when are women
actually saying like constantly
obviously can happen some I mean we're
human being like we get sick too but
like when our women are actually saying
constantly I got a day kanana man forgot
about it because she doesn't want you to
animal like me personally like when I
actually end up
actually a very long relationship it was
for that reason like there was no way I
didn't like it anymore like I wasn't in
love anymore so there was it also sex
was missing so she actually right if you
actually such a you know won't you want
your men
so so if women stop having sex with men
you're saying the man should just leave
because at that point you know it's done
yeah yeah it can happen once in a while
because you you know that's real reason
like you just had the baby you're you
know surgery whatever but like when it
becomes something constantly that I'm
gonna say no no men just leave sometimes
she says no once go somewhere else I'm
not even where yeah because he probably
pays I'm sorry I can't take rejection
yeah I mean I ain't rejected nobody else
so as far as long as if your mind's
coming to you and you're his woman and
you're gonna say no leave don't give a
chance to say no to you again because
there's lots of women out there don't
forget how many to one yeah he doesn't
want this how many two one there'll be
lots of women out there gonna say yes to
you so don't let a woman come and tell
you no no no I've fallen out in love
with you so then leave us in leave the
relationship leave the relationships
leave that's the part I'm trying to make
auntie I got a question for you what
should I do if his wife gets fat liver
no seriously no no no no no because come
on you meet a woman why you mean listen
if you can't help her
right and she won't help herself leave
her yeah because that's changing the
contract because you never married her
like that I'm the same size now as I was
36 years ago
and as far as I'm concerned my man
thinks I'm fat now because I put on four
pounds so I've got to lose that four
pound yeah I mean because I was four
pound heavier but as far as I'm
concerned
if the women there and they're eating
they're eating they're eating they're
eating they're eating they don't want to
help themselves leave them why oh if not
and you're married keep on feeding them
and just ensure her buy all the
fattening foods going just kill her off
and just let me die natural causes and
claim the money back
so okay so do he should leave his wife
if she starts sleeping with him and if
she gets that what else what other
reasons What which thing is she can't
cook she can't clean because she can't
listen right a woman needs to do all of
them things before you put a ring on her
finger if the woman can't cook take her
home to Mummy I'll hit your mother can't
cook but no she needs to learn how to
cook I have to clean and money she needs
to know how to sort out her finances not
like oh I've got a belong going to go to
Daddy they need to sort of because too
many women waste money and the women the
men let them waste the money and then
they waste all their money and then they
want to go and spend the men's well yeah
women women own 70 to 80 of Consumer
Debt even though they um they make less
money I bet 9 out of ten women got
clothes in their in their in their
closet that still got tags on yeah yeah
yeah yeah you see men don't do that and
women by stuff that's fashionable every
time they want to renew the fashion
remember classic clothes that they can
wear this year next year the year after
but women just women just waste money
you want a woman that's good with money
good in bed good with children can cook
was it a chef in the kitchen
a [ __ ] in the bedroom a nanny
and a cleaner that woman's got to be I
think there's about five different
things that you want in one woman guys
how did that how does that sound to you
let's just no it's a feedback on what
she's saying no no it sounds good and
and like look to be honest yeah I don't
think it's asking much
you know it's not it's not over and
beyond for those things you know the
basic things like you said cooking
cleaning just
like and if you've been raised a certain
way you would have been you would have
known that naturally anyway do you know
what I mean and then you bring that into
a relationship to be honest the best
sort of raised women no matter what
country they're from are those that are
raised to be trash no yeah exactly so
when they come into the relationship oh
um can you cook it's a standard twerk
can you roll a dumpling can you do food
of course you've got to take off your
fingers for do you wear gloves this
season me come on there you go even even
on a black level even little things like
can you plant do you know what I mean
little things like that is like
if they then they come with no it's like
who raised you type of thing so by the
time you've got there you've got two
three four of the things naturally
already